[Music]
this is not my
world I've never been to this Lake
before never walked its
Shores but I will find my way back and I
will find my way back to my
Molly 5 years ago I was left in this
dark place
going let sh taken from my
wife the of the people here have no hope
you still looking for that wife of yours
you're clinging to scraps of rumors and
then he
arrived where's my wife I shifted her
for every choice you make there are
countless other realities where you make
a different Choice you're talking about
parallel Earths imagine having the power
to move people from One reality to the
next to shift
them what do you want with me I can make
you a king imagine everything you have
ever
wanted work for me and get back with the
woman that you love okay we go on a date
and maybe we kiss hopefully he's might
to shift you back your wife it's a trick
I choose you that's the last Choice I'm
ever going to
make I will never leave you
alone I've seen a bunch of people like
us out there looking for a little
hope there is nothing that I won't do to
you
you can't just shoot the
devil there was so much evil and
inhumanity in this world but there is
also Beauty and hope and I will find my
way back to
[Music]
her